hi everyone I'm Ibrahim ok from YouTube
API developer relations team and joining
you today from New York today we will
talk about in live streaming
implementation called xsplit and I'm
sure if you guys are playing games and
straining them live you're already
familiar with this amazing product
xsplit but today we are really lucky to
have Henry clavering and niggle mana
from xsplit to join us and talk about
the product hi guys thanks thanks so
much for joining us good to be here
thank you very much thanks and today
actually we'll talk about the product
and hopefully we'll see like a nice live
demo but to start can talk about the
history of the product and what are the
goals behind this yeah definitely well
originally we split media labs was
really organized as a development team
in European a privately owned
outsourcing company called world partner
the team started off developing a set of
multimedia applications for visual
communication and the app that we
developed back then was called expert
capture and and that was really more of
a like 12 few communication video
communication product and that's the
product based on which we got funding
and creatives but media labs as a
company in Hong Kong back 2009 this
product this was totally different from
how expert broadcasters is is to date
and basically it evolved from expert
capture expert capture was only
published in an internal better and from
the feedback we got there and the
requirements we discover from users and
so forth we sort of changed it from from
a simple screen capture with camera
thing into into a real internet TV
application that we have today okay
great can you just show us a live demo
of the product absolutely absolutely we
can do that so yeah I'll I'll just boot
up expert here and
yeah probably some people might note
that it doesn't exactly look like the
expert that they know and that's because
the new version of expert that we're
using here for this demo so for those
who don't know xsplit the expert has 12
scenes that you can see here in the
right corner and we've got input sound
and system sounds I can drag as you can
see an image to my first scene and on my
second scene i'm going to add staff to
which i'm playing in the background here
so i've now got two scenes set up and
i'm ready to add my youtube live channel
i just go to the broadcast menu at the
channel and then I just fill out my
credentials google youtube credentials
and i need to authorize first using the
oauth2 and just typing in my password so
this all runs from google servers and
can take a little time not because it's
google servers and then yeah we got
authenticated and we can add a
description title and we can also set
our category these things we can change
as we go live but now we're done setting
up the channel so when we do go live now
you can see the title bar changes and we
get a prompt here so we can now select
whether we want to do an ad hoc event or
connect to an existing scheduled event
we can also change our description tax
and so forth category just before we go
live so consider the initial setup as a
template sold speed so once relied then
we've got its got a link in our
clipboard and we can try and test that
off test that out to see it for light
and yeah hopefully it's it's it's gonna
show up in short while it can take a
little time in the meantime can you talk
about like the new features in the new
product maybe the I assume that you guys
had like an upload feature as well you
you you can see as I was you know some
of the features in the new product is
what we're seeing right here once we
hover our mouse and crawl on top of the
scenes we can see a preview immediately
and that's definitely one of the new
features so anyway now as you can see we
got live and i'm just gonna gonna stop
this broadcast now and yeah i'll just
show you another new feature here a very
interesting thing which is a which is
our which is our epic feature that
allows expert to upload videos and track
videos straight leon on youtube so as
you can see here the preview that's one
of the features we're hovering on mouse
across the scenes and we can see the
preview can see what's behind the scene
basically right now you can see on scene
to my snack wrap was there alright so
that's one of the things that's
brilliant thing with a new version of
product so now i've made a small
recording and i can then go to my
recordings where i can see the recording
i just made i can change the thumbnail
view and so this recording i can
actually i can share in facebook twitter
and google+ for the first thing to share
on youtube i need to upload to YouTube
when I can set my title and my privacy
settings there and I can straight to go
and upload it that also could take a few
seconds but our video is not that big so
so that should be up in a few seconds
yeah we have to make the little patience
perhaps so anyway once it's up we can
see it here it has a link and and we can
just check it out to see that it
actually got uploaded well it's being
processed but it certainly yeah well
just uh it'll just take a minute out
what it sits there already i thing yeah
so that's the video we just we just
recorded a few few minutes ago let's
grab so as you can see there's a small
like consider read a little red thing in
the video before and that was what that
was upload to YouTube now we were
sharing it on Facebook and we can share
on twitter as well and so these sharing
features and certainly also yeah google+
and these sharing features all requires
that it's uploaded to youtube first nice
so yeah we actually yeah we track the
videos there so next time you open
expert you can see what videos in your
in my video recordings that was actually
that was on that's already on YouTube
sounds great and thanks for like this
amazing demo can just talk a bit about
how this app implemented what
programming languages did you use yeah
certainly so all our core is built in
C++ because we have a lot of functions
that are very close to the operating
system so that's sort of what we found
most suitable and the UI and other
functions such as for example youtube
live broadcast plugin is built using a
c-sharp was there any reason that you
guys use the C sharp well it's a it's a
pretty a lot of people know C sharp and
and it's easier usually to develop in a
face using C sharp so I think that's why
we
originally chose C sharp okay maybe we
all talked about if you guys use the or
a PS through the client libraries or
just like the straight to the cold well
I think I can answer that initially we
were trying to implement it in C++ but
since when we started our implementation
the live ap I was very much in beta and
a lot of things were changing so it
would give us bear it was highly
impractical for us to keep rewriting our
rest code in C++ so we just settled for
the c-sharp client library that that's
provided by you guys yeah so i should
mention that you guys were one of the
first implemented first using the beta
version as well and by using that kind
of talk about if you're using the other
other API is besides the live streaming
because I saw you were doing uploads
that you were also tracking the videos
yes we're actually using the data API
both version 2 and version 3 we mainly
use the version 3 API but for tracking
our videos such a such as tagging it
with developer tags we have to use the
version 2 data API because that's the
only library that supports developer
tags but we do hope that you will
support developer tags in the newer
version yeah there's definitely a
request on that and we hope to have the
developer taxonomy tree as well and
besides that can you guys share another
feedbacks or where you guys at have any
like surprise moments when you were
implementing this API well back when
when we started we were actually
surprised that there was no like
viewercount that was I think early this
year but it's already implemented now in
your in your latest release so easy with
that and we're also surprised with the
way broadcasts and streams were like
kind of different because we've been
within our other use cases we just kind
of stream straight to an end point and
that's if they have one endpoint and
then we we take note of
nice ring to it but in your in your API
there you create multiple stream objects
and then you bind them to broadcast
objects which are the actual events and
from what I understand is the stream
objects away so that the end points can
be reusable and the settings are very
much preset so you can just select which
particular broadcast resolution you're
going to be going for and then just bind
it to an event I think that's how you
want it yeah definitely some right for
me already and are there any like
features or do you guys wants to be sure
that Percy or prioritize um currently I
guess we would like to enable our
broadcasters to be able to interact with
the wits with the users more or what
sorry where there were the viewers more
and to do that we need some sort of
implementation for your life comments
but we also noticed a big delay uh from
the real-time broadcast to the actual
thing that you see on youtube so there's
like a 40 45 second delay and that would
probably kill any any sort of real-time
interaction between users and viewers
and broadcasters yeah yeah I think I
think it's right i mean the big missing
feature right now is really low latency
and then real-time comments yes we see a
lot of the big streams in gaming we're
really that the broadcast of feeds off
the user's comments do this go there and
they really have a wonderful you know
interaction there and and so we'd love
to see that and on YouTube live as well
that that's the biggest visit feature
right yeah risa yeah thanks for the
valuable feedback I'm sure actually we
are like really it doing like or best to
get like Layton's to the lowest as
possible and hopefully will commence in
feature and maybe like to summarize I
heard like sure you guys will say like
opportunities in xsplit as well care you
got total bit
yeah absolutely so we're definitely also
hiring next foot you can go to expert
com / careers and I think we have
positions open both for like 6 plus
develops you shop developers web
developed and so forth and our
development center is located in Manila
so what we're certainly also accepting
applications from from from developers
from other countries us and and and so
forth so so yeah that'd be great galax
be calm / careers and and see if that
might be position you guys would like to
buy for oh yeah thanks so much for
joining me today guys that was like a
really nice to see the live demo and
talk about texted product then it really
like hope to like see like the new
features and the new version publicly
available really soon that was great to
be home thank you yeah thank you for
having us thanks up and lovely I really
want to like finish up with saying that
you also there's a google developer
relations team we are hiring almost
everywhere in the world you can always
like check the options from
developers.google.com/jobs and thanks
for joining me today guys and have a
nice day ibrahim will care from New York